bonsoir
alors alors vous êtes le parrain des
anges de l'enfer les fameux hells angels
3000 membres répartis dans 120 pays à
travers 180 club et vous êtes ici à
l'occasion de la publication rage burger
de votre autobiographie qui s'appelle fc
hull chez flammarion voilà alors vous
parler comme ça parce que vous avez une
une ablation du larynx je crois
c'est parce que je fumais
ggg contracter un cancer on m'a enlevé
de la rance pour me garder en vie ou
fumier quoi
[Musique]
mais kamel ipad marque
mais est ce que ça fait de la pub bien
alors aujourd'hui vous parler un petit
peu comme marlon brando dans le parrain
oui mais je ne suis pas le pain quand
même d'accord alors c'est quoi les hells
angels pour nous qui ne savons pas
et bien c'est un groupe de personnes qui
se sont réunies pour faire de la moto et
s'amuser alors que ça a démarré en
californie
etats-unis dont et puis nous sommes
détendus sur le monde entier alors quand
interpol dit que les hells angels sont
l'une des plus grandes organisations
criminelles internationales
quand le ministère de la justice
américain a dit que les hells compte
parmi les 15 principaux cartels de la
drogue aux usa vous répondez quoi
tout ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'était vrai ben alors pourquoi perdre
mon temps à écrire des livres pour
gagner de l'argent oui bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
ceci étant
ceux ci étant vous avez été arrêté pour
pour trafic de drogue quand même
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas vrai je n'ai
jamais été emprisonné pour pour cela on
m'a mis en prison parce que je possédais
des petites quantités de droit où
j'avais une toute petite quantité de
cocaïne et cinq joints de marijuana et
doute pas pilule de quelque chose est un
tout petit peu d'héroïne moins de 20
grammes et on m'a mis en prison à vie
pour ça évidemment la peine a été
renversé au bout de six mois c'est quand
même fou qu'on vous ait mis dans un
pénitencier aussi dur que celui de
folsom juste parce que vous aviez un
petit peu de cocaïne et quelques joints
de marijuana quand même
mais je suis dur moi aussi alors autre
raison de la mauvaise réputation des
hells angels c'est l'imagerie nazis et
quand on lit votre votre livre en fait
on se rend compte que vous lancez la
mode de l'imagerie nazis chez les hells
angels complètement par inadvertance un
jour un copain à vous vous offre une
ceinture de l'armée allemande avec un
aigle perché sur une vaste ica avec la
mention dieu est avec nous et ensuite ça
devient une mode vous ne contrôlez plus
et cette mode vous dépasse et tous les
hells angels commence à avoir des
insignes nazis
effectivement nous n'étions pas des
mazilles c'était tout à fait tout à fait
fortuit mais alors quand on s'est rendu
compte de la chose et qu'il y avait des
gens du monde entier qui sont associés à
ça on a arrêté évidemment l'insigne
nazim mais comment expliquez vous que
dans la plupart des pays du monde
les hells angels sont proches
des néo nazis ou des mouvements
d'extrême droite
je sais pas comment on peut dire une
chose pareille parce qu'après tout nous
ne sommes pas associés à ces mouvements
regardez où nous sommes la seule chose
que vous trouverez chez les hells angels
qui lui donne une mauvaise image c'est
la police qui nous il nous dénigrer
sinon on ne dit pas ce moment là
pourquoi ne pas nous mettre tous sentent
aussi nous étions vraiment décrit lunel
évidemment il ya des gens qui se font
arrêter tous les jours mais pour des
petites choses idiotes et puis après on
est obligé d'être remise en liberté
parce qu'il ya aucune preuve de quoi que
ce soit alors on dit aussi que les hells
angels sont racistes est ce que c'est
vrai qu'il faut être blanc pour faire
partie des hells angels
non je sais pas tout à fait vrai ça
c'est vrai que la grande majorité
effectivement sont blancs mais il ya des
gens de toutes les races tous notre de
notre club il ya des hells angels noir
oui il y en a quelques-uns un bon jamais
vu moi-même bon alors aussi dans les
reproches qui sont faits aux hells
angels ont dit que les hells angels sont
misogynes
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que les
femmes sont plus mal traités chez vous
je sais pas si les femmes sont moins
bien traités que les hommes enfin on est
et est pas allé comme moi je suis sur ma
quatrième femme maintenant tôt pris je
les aime bien nous ne nous aimons les
femmes croyez moi alors évidemment c'est
faux pas partie du club c'est parce que
c'était un club quand même masculin et
nous ne sommes pas subventionnés par
l'état ne peuvent pas nous obliger à
accepter des femmes en notre sein mais
c'est notre choix alors vous dites que
partout où il ya des hells angels il ya
des femmes qui veulent avoir du bon
temps et vous raconter que pas mal de
femmes respectables sont secrètement en
fait attirés par les hells angels c'est
à dire les types macho un peu sauvage et
que beaucoup
veulent subir des gangs bangs de la part
des bandes de hell's angels
non ça j'ai jamais dit le chauffeur est
en tout cas ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de femmes qui sont
effectivement attiré par les cyclistes
par les motocyclistes qui a beaucoup de
femmes également qu' il y fréquente
parce qu'elle aime l'aventuré disons
alors ce soir de game 1 de mox j'ai pas
entendu parler de ce genre d'histoire
enfin j'imagine qu'à des femmes qui a
fait fantasmer je suis désolé mais dans
votre livre vous dites page 149 il y
avait sans arrêt des gang bang
j'aimerais comme un fils un dollar pour
chaque femme venue me trouver au cours
d'une de nos fiesta me demande en
utiliser une chambres vacantes en
compagnie d'un groupe de bandar prêts à
se mettre à l'ouvragé pour un certain
genre de nanas c'était un honneur de se
faire trancher par une bande hells
angels certaines des femmes qui nous
voyait en train de débouler sur les
routes n'étaient ni terrorisé ni
offusqué elle voulait être de la partie
même si c'est à signifier se caler à
l'arrière de la bécane de l'étranger sur
you're talking bas de gamme bang
j'ignore book vous parler des grandes
banques
alors il faudrait que je vous présente
mes excuses parce que je ne me rendais
pas compte que j'avais écrit ce passage
j'ai écrit ce livre il ya 3 3 ou 4 ans
et j'en ai écrit deux depuis je
travaille sur deux autres dit et j'avais
oublié ce passage quand on pense aux
hells angels on pense bien entendu au
concert des rolling stones halte à mon
le fameux concert où meredith hunter a
été assassiné alors pourquoi les hells
angels ont été incapables d'assurer la
sécurité ce jour-là al tammo
les rolling stones l'est pas
se présenter il voulait il voulait
chauffer la foule voulait chauffer leur
public alors on les a faits attendre une
heure et demie alors là évidemment
commencer à faire noir la foule
commençait vraiment à être assez agitée
j'étais là j'ai depuis 48 heures les
gens commençaient à être un petit peu
indiscipliné alors qu'enfin les rolling
stones se sont montés sur scène alors il
ya eu un mouvement de foule qui s'est
précipité vers la seine au dessus de nos
motos alors ce qu'ils ont monté son à
moto nous sommes descendus de la scène
pour justement les repousser mais ils
sont affiliés d'une cinquantaine de
mètres et tout ça vous le verrez dans
l'ordre dans le film
shirt il a raison commencé à balancer
des bouteilles de bière et autres alors
j'ai essayé de protéger la scène en
repoussant certains des spectateurs mais
comme les gens nous taper dessus et
comme bias défense vous dites ce que
vous voulez mais lorsqu'on jette des
trucs faut bien se défendre
toujours est il que il ya eu donc cette
espèce des changes pendant quelques
temps et puis la personne qui s'est fait
assassiner en fait j'étais panacée
cinéaste yann un suicide cette personne
s'est jetée sur scène c'était rejeter il
a sorti un flingue a tiré sur la foule
et puis à quelqu'un qui l'a qui l'a
poignardée voilà comment les choses se
sont passées alors
s'il ya quelqu'un qui vous tirent dessus
qu'est ce que vous allez faire je me
défendre ouais
c'est légitime défense en fait pour vous
à mon sens le type qui l'a poignardée
bon sens le veau on le voit cette
personne s'est fait arrêté jugé et on a
vu dans le film après ça que la personne
a été acquitté voilà alors vous dites
qu'on fait halte à mon les stones
voulait un environnement inquiétant pour
pouvoir jouer sympathy for the devil
penser qu'en fait il était content de ce
qui s'est passé
je pense qu'effectivement et j'étais
assez satisfait
alors vous dites en parlant notamment
quant à moi les années 70 ils m'ont
amené dans tellement de trucs tellement
dingue que finalement ça c'était plutôt
un pique nique à l'église en fait
c'était un jour typique dans la vie des
rased jose qui s'est dit hier que on
allait dans les conserves et d'abyei à
quelqu'un nous tirent dessus se fait
huer bon voilà c'est la routine
oui alors les singles ont toujours été
anti pacifiste dans les années 60 en
californie ils ont souvent casser du
pacifiste et ils sont souvent pro guerre
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
favorables à l'intervention américaine
en irak
moi j'appuie ce que fait notre
gouvernement
a me semble que si le gouvernement
estime qu'il faut intervenir et pas
c'est qu'il a raison alors je ne suis
pas sûr des raisons je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il fasse les choses correctement
cela étant s'il faut y aller faut y
aller il faut gagner la guerre vainqueur
merci merci d'un casque et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux